ميرسي اسطوره خطه تاريخها هذا الطفل الذي
يروي كيف كان يلعب في نادي الحي صغيرا
بمسقط راسه بروساريو ويحلم باللعب مع
المنتخب منها انطلق الى العالميه وحقق
اكثر مما كان يحلم به مع ابن مدينته
ديماريه ليجلب اليها والى بلاده كاس
العالم اختار متحف مدينته بولايه سانتافي
وضع نسخه اصليه منه الى جانب صوره ظاهره
مارادونا ليؤكد ان ابنهم بات ايقونه
ارجنتينيه كذلك والى جانبه عدد من نجوم
المنتخب
روساريو مصنع دايو لاكبر النجوم في كره
القدم وقد اثبت ذلك في اخر مونديال حيث
خرج منها النجم الكبير ميسي وهنا نحتفظ
بقميص طفولته
قبل انتقاله الى برشلونه بعمر 13 عاما لكن
تحقيق اول اهدافه كان هنا في نادي كردبه
حيث يسترجع زميله ذكرياتهما
معانا
كنت اشعر انه مختلفون واثبت ذلك في كل شيء
في طريقه لاعبه وموهبته وشخصيته
لا ينسى مدير نادي حركات واداء ميسي
الاستثنائي بين اقرانه في زوايا هذا
الملعب رغم معاناته حينها من نقص النمو
الشهيره التي قالها بلهجه ابناء المدينه
وقد حافظ على وفائها
الصغير ويحتاج الى العلاج وكلنا نتمنى
علاجه لكن لم نستطيع كان يتمتع باداء غير
عادي لدينا صور له
فهو يتجاوز اللاعبين بمهاره منذ صغاره
الطريق المؤديه الى منزله في مسقط راسه
فرحا باحضاره النجمه الثالثه لبلدهم
وتتنوع اشكال تعبيرهم البعض علق رساله شكر
على باب منزل العائله والاخر ترك توقيعه
او رسمه لوحه وهو ينظر الى حلمه وقد بات
حقيقه
اما في اول ملعب دهسته قدما ميسي على
زاويه الحي فيلعب اطفال حين تسالهم عن
حلومهم يجيبون
ذاته يتمناه ابناء الولايات التي اختار
نجمهم احد منتجعاتها للاستجمام بعد
المونديال الى الولايات التي خرج منها عاد
ليو ميسي
وبلده بكاس العالم انها قصه ظاهره
ارجنتينيه ثانيه مع المنتخب الوطني
يشتعلوا الجدل في المقارنه بينهما لكن
يبقى ان ما يجمعهما هو تحقيق بطوله العالم
لبلدهما حسن مسعود الجزيره سانتفه